[Music]
speaking from philadelphia the city
known as the birthplace of american
democracy president joe biden delivered
a prime time address declaring that u.s
democratic values are under assault i've
come to this place where it all began
to speak as plainly as i can
to the nation
about the threats we face
using sharp and combative language biden
targeted his political rival by name
repeatedly former president donald trump
biden has called trump's make america
great again or mega-republican followers
semi-fascists donald trump and the
migrant republicans
represented extremism
that threatens the very foundations of
our republic
with just eight weeks until voters go to
the polls for midterm congressional
elections and trump now the focus of a
criminal investigation into alleged
mishandling of classified documents
biden sending a message that a vote in
november for some opposition republicans
is a danger to democracy
but republicans fired back with their
own speech president biden has chosen to
divide
demean
and disparage his fellow americans
why
simply because they disagree with his
policies
they accused biden of weaponizing the
federal government to eliminate his
political opposition joe biden in a
politicized department of justice
launched a raid on the home of his top
political rival donald trump
that is an assault on democracy
republicans also accused biden of
mishandling the economy and being soft
on immigration they're issues that in
recent months caused biden's approval
ratings to plummet the white house hopes
this forceful rebuke of trump and his
followers will turn things around
there are dangers around us
we cannot allow to prevail
we hear you've heard it
more and more talk about violence
as an acceptable political tool
in this country
it's not
since sharpening his attacks on former
president trump president biden's
approval ratings have been rising it's
momentum he hopes will help his
democratic party retain control of
congress come voting day in november
kimberly helkin al jazeera the white
house